on this episode of AI adventures find
out what Kegel Colonel's are and how to
get started using this though there's no
popcorn in this episode I can assure you
that Kegel kernels are Papa tango is a
platform for doing and sharing data
science you may have heard about some of
their competitions which often have cash
prizes it's also a great place to
practice data science and learn from the
community tackle kernels are essentially
Jupiter notebooks in the browser that
can be run right before your eyes all
free of charge
let me say that again in case you missed
it because this is truly quite amazing
cackled kernels is a free platform to
run Jupiter notebooks in your browser
this means that you can save yourself
the hassle of setting up a local
environment and have a Jupiter notebook
environment right inside your browser
anywhere in the world that you have an
internet connection not only that the
processing power for the notebook comes
from servers up in the clouds not your
local machine so you can do a lot of
data science and machine learning
without heating up your laptop Kongo
also recently upgraded all their kernels
to have more compute power and more
memory as well as extending the length
of time that you can run a notebook cell
to up to 60 minutes but ok enough of me
gushing about Kaggle kernels let's see
what it actually looks like once we
create an account at Cal calm we can
choose a data set that we want to play
with and spin up a new kernel or
notebook in just a few clicks the data
set that we started in comes pre-loaded
in the environment of that kernel so
there's no need to deal with pushing a
data set into that machine or waiting
for large data sets to copy over a
network of course you can still load
additional files into the kernel if you
want in our case we'll continue to play
with our fashion and this data set it's
a data set that contains 10 categories
of clothing and accessory types things
like pants bags heels shirts and so on
there are 50,000 training samples and
10,000 evaluation samples let's explore
the data set in our kaggle kernel
looking at the dataset it's provided on
cattle in the form of CSV files the
original data was in a 28 by 28 pixel
grayscale images and they've been
flattened to become 784 distinct columns
in the CSV file the file also contains a
column representing the index 0 through
9 of that fashion item since the data
set is already in the environment and
pandas is already loaded let's use it to
read these CSV files into pandas
dataframes now that we've loaded the
data into a data frame we can take
advantage of all the features that this
brings which we covered in the previous
episode we'll display the first five
rows with head and we can run describe
to learn more about the structure of the
data set additionally it would be good
to visualize some of these images so
that they can have more meaning to us
than just rows upon rows of numbers
let's use matplotlib to see what some of
these images look like here we'll use
the matplotlib pie plot library
typically imported as PLT to display the
arrays of pixel values as images we can
see that these images while fuzzy are
indeed still recognizable as the
clothing and accessory items that they
claim to be I really like that kagu
kernels lets me visualize my data in
addition to just processing it so Calvin
kernels allows us to work in a fully
interactive notebook environment in the
browser with little to no setup and I
really want to emphasize that we didn't
have to do any sort of Python
environment configuration or
installation of libraries which is
really cool thanks for watching this
episode of cloudy I adventurous be sure
to subscribe to the channel to catch
future episodes as they come out now
what are you waiting for head on over to
Kaggle comm and sign up for an account
to play with kernels today though
there's no popcorn in this episode I can
assure you that Kengo kernels got a
throw harder wait are you gonna throw it
this way or this way though there's no
popcorn in this episode I can assure you
now if the cone kernels are popping